it is a welcome sight
and sound every winter hundreds of
thousands of migratory birds
fill the skies of indian-administered
kashmir among them
geese egrets ducks and cormorants all
traveling thousands of kilometers from
eastern europe japan and turkey to feed
and breed here but the himalayan
wetlands
are becoming less welcoming
it's always cold this time of year but
this year it's too harsh
it's making it difficult for the birds
to find food on their own
we've started artificial feeding by
giving them patty grains
this winter temperatures have dropped to
minus 10 degrees celsius
wildlife officials are forced to break
the ice on the wetlands
before scattering paddy grain they row
their boats out onto the lakes to cover
as much ground as possible
we work really hard to take care of
birds as these days the water surface at
hokkaiser freezes
we have to make a feeding pool we spread
the grain and try our best so that these
birds don't starve
around half a million migratory birds
have visited the hokusai wetlands since
november
but their numbers have declined in
recent decades years of climate change
and urban development are being blamed
hokkaisa itself has shrunk from nearly
19 square kilometers in 1969
to 12.8 today but the 10 security
situation in the area has made it
difficult to address
environmental issues in the kashmir
valley a region known as much for its
natural beauty
as the decades-long battle against
indian rule
elizabeth puranam al jazeera new delhi